I'm coffea and I'm very happy to be here
endeavors where we are discussed in all
sorts of issues but one of the important
issues is a question of the engagement
of course the future belongs to and when
we look at the dramatics today so many
young all in all we need to really
picking out are engaged and they need to
attend obviously our they committed and
make sure that it does we discuss issues
of the future for this climate change
whether its restructuring of the economy
how we green planet we do and gain the
young people I also urge the young
people come sites to reach out not wait
for people to come to the farm to sit
down come up with their own ideas to let
we bailed Islam what they want what they
want to do and generally I believe we
should also speak to them normally when
men you want an architect you get an act
when you went a lawyer you can have but
when we want you know about our plan
intense believe we have a tendency not
to talk to them to assume we know better
so it does sit back engage us at let's
plan our well together thank